welcome back to the show everybody one
more time for bill Conti and the
orchestra they've been all know you
they've been in there all week ladies
and gentlemen at night we just seal this
shot you haven't eaten anything I got a
fun-sized chocolate you want anything
you split it a hundred ways oh for God's
sakes they ate the third trombonist
that's just terrible
we got there they're they're the best
well done one more time for those guys
there I thought you were playing me off
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
two-time Academy Award nominee John
Travolta
on the movie set they're called the DP
director of photography in this room we
call them cinematographers either way
you want if you want the very best you
call one of these five nominees the
nominees for outstanding achievement in
cinematography are wally pfister for
Batman Begins Rodrigo Prieto the
Brokeback Mountain Robert Elsbeth for
good night and good luck
Giambi be for Memoirs of a Geisha
Emanuela the best be for the New World
and the Oscar goes to you here we go
Dion B be from Mars of a Geisha
this is the first Oscar and second
nomination for the MVP he was previously
nominated for Chicago
Oh God what an amazing feeling
terrifying but amazing mom I know you're
up there somewhere
I think getting a rub Marshall I know
you're here too I want to you know thank
you for you know like was said earlier
this was your vision and we feel like we
were a part of it and you know I hope we
made you proud and you know to Sony
Pictures for being brave enough to to
make this movie and great producers my
beautiful wife who's over there who is
my inspiration and and and my muse and
to our beautiful boy at home axl who was
born during the making of this movie and
and it'll it'll it'll be a beautiful
part of my life forever thank you ladies
and gentlemen
recording star Jamie Foxx